عن قرب نتابع ابرز التصريحات الرسميه
والقرارات التي يتم اتخاذها اتخاذها في
اداره الكوارث افاد تنضم الينا من هناك
كالعاده فرح زمان شوقي واخر التحديثات
اليك الكلمه
عبد
السلام ان اخر التحديثات التي صدرت على
لسان نائب الرئيس التركي لحسن الحظ هذه
المره لم يعطي ارقاما جديده تتعلق بارتفاع
عدد القتلى والجرحى ما زلنا عند
957 قتيلا وعدد جرحى يقارب 53 الف اوكتاي
يصف
الكارثه ويقول بان الاضرار والتبعات ضخمه
ويمكن مشاهدتها على انابيب الغاز على خطوط
السكك الحديديه يقول ان تاثيرها يكاد يكون
كتاثير قنبله نوويه هذا ما قاله هنا حرفيا
لكنهم زاد او اكد ازدياد اعداد هزات
الارتداديه التي وقعت في تلك المنطقه
اصبحت تقارب 800 هزه ارتداديه منذ وقوع
الزلزال ويقول ان مئه الف يشاركون في
عمليات الانقاذ الان
ويتحدث عن مساعدات عرضت على تركيا من 66
دوله وصل منها
مساعدات من 31 دوله وبالحديث عن المساعدات
الجزيره طرحنا كفريق الجزيره طرحنا سؤالا
عليه حول
وصول المساعدات الى سوريا
فرد هنا وزير الخارجيه وليس نائب الرئيس
التركي ليؤكد بان هذا الملف انساني وليس
سياسي وتركيا ستحاول تسهيل وصول المساعدات
الى سوريا يقول انه ان تركيا تعمل الان
على فتح معبرايين في المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها النظام وكرر بان هذا الملف انساني
وليس سياسي حتى انه من الممكن ان يفتح
المجال الجوي لارسال المساعدات لحلب في
وقت لاحق وفي الوقت الذي دار فيه الحديث
عن وجود صعوبات لوجستيه تعقد مرور
المساعدات عبر المع مع تركيا يؤكد وزير
الخارجيه التركي بان كل المساعدات التي
ستصل الى سوريا عبر تركيا ستعمل تركيا في
وقت لاحق على القيام بمهامها وتسهيل
مرورها الى الاراضي السوريه رغم حجمي وهول
الكارثه على كلا البلدين ويؤكد بان تعامل
مع هذا الملف هو تعامل انساني وليس سياسي
بالعوده لتصريحات نائب الرئيس التركي يؤكد
هنا او يتحدث عن عمليات الانقاذ ويؤكد
الحاجه
للمزيد من الرافعات بسبب انهيار ابنيه
كبيره وضخمه ولكنه يشير الى ان البحث هو
التنقيب قد شارف على الانتهاء في خمسه من
الولايات العشره وهذا امر جيد كون فرق
الانقاذ ستنقل من هذه المناطق الخمس الى
المناطق الخمس الاخرى الاكثر تضر لذلك من
المتوقع ان يزداد اعداد فرق الدعم في
المناطق الاكثر تضررا في واحده دون اخرى
يؤكد ايضا ان الان هنالك تسهيل لعمليات
اجلاء الراغبين في مغادره تل تلك المناطق
المنكوبه لان ذلك ايضا سيسهل عمل فرق
الانقاذ اكثر
بالنسبه للمطارات يؤكد بانها اصبحت مفتوحه
باستثناء مطار هاتاي اذ ان الاضرار فيه ما
زالت كبيره للغايه
الطاقه والغاز والكهرباء هناك محاولات
لاصلاح هذه الخطوط وتامين ايصالها تدريجيا
دون او مع محاوله لوقف وقوع اي نتائج
سلبيه لوصل الكهرباء الى تلك المناطق من
قبيل الحرائق بالنسبه لميناء اسكندرون
اعطى اخر التحديثات والمعلومات ليؤكد بان
انه تم السيطره على الحرائق وقال انها انه
كان من الطبيعي ان يحدث هذا الحريق الضخم
وذلك بسبب ان واحده من
الحاويات الموجوده هناك كان يوجد فيها
بنزين ومحروقات وهو ما ادى لانتشار
النيران واضطرت طواقم الانقاذ ان تحاول
اطفاء هذه النيران من البر والبحر وايضا
عبر مروحيات لذلك اخذ هذا الامر وقتا
طويلا في ظل وجود
كارثه كبيره على الارض وهي
رفع الانقاض
وانقاذ العالقين تحتها عبد السلام